all right so let's review some sequel
itis frozen to so frozen to is the
sequel to the ridiculously successful
frozen there's this enchanted forest
it's calling to Elsa there's a curse
there's a mystery they have to uncover
the mystery and now here we go really
what this movie has working for it other
than you know really impressive CGI when
else is doing a song you see you're like
do the decrying gasps which hits the
empathetic party or Brailler oh I want
to really empathize with her not because
of anything she's actually saying you're
doing but because I see that she's sad
but the CGI is really good when it's
exciting it's really exciting when it's
intriguing it's actually really
intriguing but the biggest thing this
movie has going for it is Elsa and onna
their dynamic together you get that
sisterly bond you get that sisterhood
they work well together while they're
together oh my god if this movie ever
splits them up that would be stupid it
totally does while they're together
though really good and they're dynamic
works well together because they work
well as a yin and yang pair and it works
against Elsa because I'm just gonna say
it
Elsa is a boring emo chick and it's very
fun and vibrant and full of life Elsa
needs to be around Anna in order for me
to care when she's not with her I'm like
I make fractals that's I care about that
as for the story I thought the story in
this movie is really good I felt it was
a really intriguing and interesting
story execution-wise not as interesting
as it was on paper this is one of those
plots where someone brought the plot to
somebody on paper who's just the outline
the concept they're like oh wow that
sounds epic
let's do it and then characters dialogue
you know a movie happened the script was
formed and then it's like well it's not
as interesting as it sounded on paper
and the movie could have been amazing
it's just it's all right you see the
mystery before the mystery is even there
you're like okay I'll bet you this is
the big reveal
oh look at that it is it's just that
obvious which makes me think all right
well this movie's probably made for 10
year olds 10 year olds aren't gonna see
it that obvious but their parents are
gonna be there like okay what are they
trying to hide this also Olaf I thought
Olaf was great in the first movie but
this is lightning in a bottle it always
happens first like something was
accidentally so good they were like oh
we need you to do that thing another
thing you didn't think was going to be
received that well well it's now a thing
can you do that thing
and it's like wayne szalinski with a
shrinking machine it worked once
accidentally then when he tried to
reproduce it just kept blowing up fruit
because he didn't know how it actually
worked
yet honey i shrunk the kids reference
[ __ ] yeah actually Olaf does have this
one scene where he's having his 3pl
moment he's telling his story I did
legitimately laugh in that scene I
thought that scene was great it's also
his good scene there's actually a few
calls in his boot around Satellite
spoilers I don't think it's spoilers
spoilers I'm just telling you something
that happens it's not like anyone dies
at the very beginning or anything like
that not gonna tell you that big reveals
or anything like that a couple things
that happen in this movie that I'd
probably save for a spoiler talk if I
cared you're gonna get it here okay so
Kristoff right he's along for the quest
he's like oh I'm going with you too I
want to be around and then he's just
like where are they this lady's like
Larry took off on their quest so you
know the quest where the movies taking
place have fun not being in it and so
yeah he just [ __ ] off for the rest of
the movie until near the end of the
movie I get it I understand the why of
it I understand why John Connor was
wasted I understand why Christoph took a
hike hour right regardless character
wise for the movie narrative Lee
speaking
those are stupid things to do to
character and Kristoff in his arc I
guess you'd call it stick out like a
sore thumb because well it's it's not
really an arc but it's like an arc
happened he has a whole musical sequence
about like are we growing apart what
does it mean and then he's gone for the
rest of the movie and then he shows up
near the end of the movie it's like he's
just kind of figured it out like he just
picked up where they left off he would
swear an entire movie of him took place
we just never saw it maybe it was in
here and they cut it out maybe it'll be
a 20-minute frozen short film at the
beginning of some other animated feature
I don't know but it throws the whole
thing off it makes you go why sticks out
like a sore thumb and it's one of the
many things that makes this movie feel
sloppy and then yeah at a point in this
movie even Elsa's like I need to go on
this quest alone so like it's like this
movie is sequentially how bands break up
they were a band a trio and then the
band push the boyfriend out alright now
they're a duo and then that duo broke up
at a point in here and now they're just
a couple of boring solo acts I'm really
bagging on this movie hard I don't mean
to I didn't hate it I thought some of
the music was catchy
even though there's not that let it go a
moment there's not that song you're like
oh wow but frozen to is one of
sequel's I can't justify its existence
because it didn't justify its own
existence this movie just makes you not
care about the characters as much as it
probably should have it makes you stop
caring about them after the first movie
made you care about them epic animation
some good last act excitement good
message good story on paper that's the
difference between potential and reality
frozen - probably would have been a
better time if I were drunk yeah no it's
a bar so frozen - have you seen it why'd
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]